Grammy winning country star is leaving
the genre that made her famous while
blasting it as toxic and racist singer
maren Morris claims that Trump years
exposed the bigoted views of people in
the industry she says quote it just
revealed who people really were and that
they were proud to be misogynistic and
racist and homophobic and transphobic
Morris is also smearing country music
fans who enjoy hit songs like Jason
Aldean's try that in a small town quote
people are streaming these songs out of
spite it's not out of true Joy or love
of the music it's to own the libs music
is supposed to be the voice of the
oppressed the actual oppressed
discussion
let's go here we go Dana you know isn't
this classic liberalism where
um you're racist or you're a misogynist
if you don't fit her narrative yeah so
she's talking about she says music is
supposed to be for the voice of the
oppressed the actual oppressed but I
mean the people are playing these songs
because it makes them feel something and
that's what music is supposed to be
about and she can write songs about joy
and you can enjoy you can enjoy those
you can play them on repeat but maybe
you like try this in a small town and
who is she to decide who gets to
um
stream a song and if they play it over
and over again you know oppression for
some people might take the form of
what's been called The Forgotten man
right and so she's mad about that and I
don't think this is necessarily going to
work for her now Taylor Swift when she
decided to blend into pop after country
she kept all of her country fans and
grew it so she wanted to do that and she
wanted to be a big star and obviously
she is I think maren Morris thinks that
she's going to do the same thing but I
think that she might be surprised
because it's not necessarily like that
the reason that country music fans like
Oliver's song or Aldine song is because
it reflects their lived experience and
that's what country music is really good
at so I think a lot of people in
Nashville would say bye bye you know
Harold I think she's the hypocrite here
and I want to know what you think she's
got a song about leaving country music
and yet she's using the country music
genre to make that song she's saying I
want no part of it but I'll take the
money and stay in it as long as I can
sing this song
yeah we did a story
um about I think it was Luke Combs
singing a song that uh someone sang
Tracy Chapman right and how people not
Tracy Chapman but somebody thought that
Tracy Chapman would be offended by this
because they assumed that the country
music world would not have accepted
Tracy this is just craziness I mean
music is about joy and empowerment and a
universal way to communicate uh in
additional lady who has a strong theory
of the case uh believes what she
believes she should go write the music
and compose the music and seeing what
she wants but there's no need to
frown on her poor try to pour gasoline
on the toxicity or an entire genre of
music sure they're people I remember
when I was growing up there were people
who made rap music and there were those
who criticized it saying that it was
preaching and there's still people who
criticized some aspects of aspects of
hip-hop saying that it promotes things
that are not positive about women and
about communities and even promoting in
glamorizing guns and violence but
there's a big part of hip-hop that does
not do that there's a part of rocks so I
think again I think this is just a
function of her age perhaps an
experience in life and I hope she's not
I hope she continues to make music let
other people make music too and we all
can decide to turn that dial or go into
that site or for that matter download
that song or not I wish her the best but
I hope she stops criticizing those that
make music in other ways you know Greg
she's not only criticizing Jason Aldean
she's criticizing his wife and calling
her an insurrectionist Barbie and a
scumbag human wow insurrectionist Barbie
is a toy I would buy
oh my God Insurrection is Barbie get on
that by the way Dana white people they
can't be oppressed did you not are you
not aware that every single white person
is a millionaire including in the Blue
Ridge Mountains wherever you go so the
real headline for this which I wrote is
country star no one heard of gets
publicity the easy way by trashing fans
and going woke however whatever
momentary Rush of infamy she gets will
fade away because because no one can
trust her but I like to help I'm a
helpful person so I rewrote some classic
country songs judge so she could sing
them without feeling that inner shame so
here we go so Stand By Your Man stand by
your whatever
Wichita Lineman Wichita klansmen mama
don't let your babies grow up to be
Cowboys mama don't let your babies grow
up to be Cowboys because they perpetuate
the patriarchy Dana These boots are made
for walking no These Boots Are Made for
drag queen Story Hour and finally Man I
Feel Like a Woman well you can leave
that one that's it
Bravo okay Jesse you know she says she
basically says that that that that
country music has a history of
misogynism and racism it's time to open
the gates you know to queers and people
of color and I have a whole list of
singers here little Nas ax Charlie Pride
Darius Rucker you know when I could go
on and on I mean she's like naive as to
what the truth is I'm still crying over
insurrectionist Barbie
in Nashville tell me it's a matter of
you can't fire me because I quit the
country music Community had
not wanted to be associated with her
anymore and she had gone on stage with
drag queens and she had gone woke she
had lost her fan base and now is trying
to transitioning into pop and I don't
think it's going to work out very
interesting you have good sources I have
one source
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else